tu la 2g de meilleur
lancé en politique
allez les jours salut l étonnement
kimono ouais ouais ouais ouais les biens
et les biens illégaux l'accident mais
l'ex époux de rennes axel bauer grande
et on ne sait pas aujourd'hui
bien sûr si je suis né parle de son
enfance à que madame les cornes et
quelle brochette mes enfants si on
m'avait dit que du rêve tu es du grand
louis semaine dernière taille ou une
semaine il faut bien ça pour des cantons
la remontée des siens d'affaires celle
là ou pas non non non allez on entend et
encore
j'temmerde on voit ce que vous
connaissez bien tout cela sacrée bande
de huawei çà çà çà un y est c'est bon
parce que le son est bon
voilà regarde on a un ingé sont un peu
fatigués jaffa jockey une oreille
absolue
celui des leçons les leçons et il est
tout seul il sera ok je peux kpg ces
manifs merci merci merci à toi merci je
suis fait peur trois belles machines
qu'ils allaient ils remuent les tripes
chez moi
ok